Speaker 1: So I know that Donald Trump is
pretending like Ron DeSantis has no chance to beat
him in a primary. And I think it's quite possible
that Ron DeSantis can't beat Trump in a primary.
But I don't believe for a second that Trump's not
worried. Trump is posting almost daily about Ron
DeSantis on Truth Social, which we will get to
a little bit later. But Trump actually seems so
panicked about DeSantis that he is lying, lying
uncontrollably about him all the time. Simple,
easily to disprove lies. Here is a clip from Trump
yesterday on Sebastian Gorka's show. If you're not
up to speed on this program, I forgive you. It's
not exactly the this show is not exactly on the
vanguard of political analysis. But in any case,
in just a few seconds, Trump tells multiple lies
about DeSantis, while ignoring the fact that the
things which he is accusing Ron DeSantis of, he
actually did himself. I won't even tell you what
they are. Let's see if you can pick them up here.
Speaker 2: Well, thank you very much. And we do
have we have such incredible spirit and love out
there. You see that in these polls. You know,
you have people they start and everybody thinks
they're wonderful. I mean, look, Ron, who I know
well, he tried to cut Social Security. He wanted
to bring the minimum age to 70 or above. He wanted
to cut Medicare. You know, let's start when people
fear that they're not going to be voting for him.
Speaker 1: Okay. There are so many lies in there
already. So So there's two parts to this. First
of all, Trump proposed cutting Medicare and Social
Security every year he was in office, either
through the budgets that he submitted, which
you can say, well, that's a political document.
It wasn't the budget that was a okay, but it's the
budget Trump submitted. Trump's budget proposal
would have cut Medicare and Social Security.
And Trump also said, if we win, the payroll tax
will be rescinded. That's how you fund Social
Security and Medicare. There is no way to get rid
of the funding source for all of Social Security
and Medicare and not to cut Social Security
and Medicare. Can't do it. It's impossible. So
Trump proposed multiple different ways that
would lead to cuts to Social Security and
Medicare. But Trump says, well, DeSantis proposed
cutting it. I'm not a defender of Ron DeSantis,
but it's not really true that Ron DeSantis did
that. What DeSantis did do three times okay,
2013, 2014, and 2015, DeSantis voted in favor of
Republican Study Committee budget resolutions,
which, if they passed, were nonbinding and
wouldn't actually have been cuts to Social
Security and Medicare. Now you can say,
well, his intention was to. Fine. It's
an exaggeration. Given Trump's background
with cutting Social Security and Medicare,
let's watch a little more of this delusional clip.
Speaker 2: And he's certainly not going to win in
a general election, but he's you're not going
to win the Republican primary, in my opinion,
either. He wants to cut Social Security. That's
not that's not good. And numerous times. You know,
he's a disciple of Paul Ryan. And Paul Ryan is
the worst is the worst. They destroyed Romney.
Mitt Romney could have won that race.
But Paul Ryan was a disaster as a pick.
That was the wheelchair over the cliff. If you
remember the famous wheelchair over the cliff,
which is what they were they started them with.
And it was very hard for them to get away from
it. They didn't get away from it. Right. So, you
know, there's a lot there's a tremendous amount
of love out there. It's it's pretty incredible.
Speaker 1: It's all love, as you can imagine.
One more clip from this interview. Here is
someone proposing that instead of wrong run,
the sanctimonious Trump instead referred to
dissenters as Ron Distant Bushman, which is,
Man, what? What a primary we're up against here.
Speaker 3: Well, we'll talk about the next
election and your comments on ballot
harvesting. But yeah, you may.
Speaker 1: We need to get to those incisive
comments about ballot ballot harvesting. Now,
three years out.
Speaker 3: Of news on truth,
social and on your recent round with your
new nickname for the governor of Florida,
Ron the sanctimonious Mr. Gee. Somebody else
has come up with a another nickname. What is
the nickname you have for us, Jeff? It's got to
be Ronald Establishment. Mr. President. Ronald
Establishment. What do you think of that?
Speaker 2: That's not bad. I've heard worse.
You know, they came out with lots of different
names. Meatball. I didn't like that one too much,
but they came out with a lot of different
names. And that's a bad I've heard of. Worse.
Speaker 1: Yeah. All right, so Trump is
workshopping other nicknames for wrong Desanctis.
There he is, just telling lies, and he'll
continue to tell those lies for as long as
he's allowed to do it. At some point, maybe
Ron DeSantis will take it head on and say
it's not true. Your budgets actually sought
to cut Social Security and Medicare For the
time being. DeSantis isn't running, so he's
not taking it on from a policy perspective.